pop and Watchman it's me Mt and welcome
back to the heavy spoiler show this is a
breakdown of the three and a half hour
ultimate cut of Zack Snyder's Watchman
this big boy is a brutal Beast of a
blast and I can't wait to get into it
with you all today so I won't so much
like the comedian did with the pavement
let's just dive into it the Watchman
movie of course is an adaptation of Alan
Moore's 1986 comic book series set in
the Cold War era of an alternate
universe of crime fighting Vigilantes
and because of the cold war setting
World War III is a threat to consuming
the minds of absolutely everyone this
being the case I love how the movie
starts with a zoom out from the
comedian's smiley face pin accompanied
by the sound of a tea kettle screeching
having this occur as the comedian
listens to a TV broadcast detailing the
rising tensions between Russia and
Afghanistan was a fantastic audible
Choice by Zack Snyder to set up this
universe of boiling tension between the
nations of the world on the brink of a
possible nuclear Armageddon and though
not mentioned directly the program that
Eddie Blake is watching is actually
Snyder's Recreation of the McLaughlin
group a popular political discussion and
debate show hosted by John McLaughlin
that ran from 1962 until John
McLaughlin's death in 2016. and Watchmen
actor Gary Houston plays the host John
McLaughlin Mary Ann Berger steps into
the shoes of prominent real-life
political reporter Eleanor Clift and
James Connor plays the role of
conservative political commentator and
politician Pat Buchanan in that
television broadcast we can see a
watchdog group of nuclear scientists
move the Doomsday Clock to 5 Minutes to
Midnight which is coincidentally the
time shown in the production studio
booth as we can see the broadcast is
being recorded at 11 55. as the comedian
watches the broadcast we can see that he
has a gun lying on top of a Hustler
magazine which I found to be the perfect
choice to summarize the personality of
the comedian right when we first are
introduced to him because the comedian's
love of fulfilling his lustful desires
is only outweighed by his love of of gun
violence and murder since the comedian
is supposed to be a living parody of
America's debauchery and brutality this
symbolism makes perfect sense but having
a gun at the ready while watching TV
also serves to show the fear and
paranoia the comedian had for all the
evil actions of his life catching up to
him one day as his long career as an
unethical government-sanctioned soldier
of war has caused this dude to Garner a
shitload of enemies which is why the
comedian is not entirely surprised by
his assassin's entrance well that and
his discovery of what his attacker
Ozymandias was truly up to when the
comedian throws his mug at his attacker
we get a slow motion shot of the mug
hitting his apartment door with the
number 3001 on it however when the monk
smashes against the door the number one
at the end of 3001 is covered by the mug
Shadow making the number look like 300
which was of course the name of Zack
Snyder's hit film that Snyder made
before shooting Watchmen however this
isn't the only reference to 300 in
Watchmen because towards the end of the
movie when New York is about to get
their new radioactive crater installed
we can see the number 300 on the lock of
rorschach's prison psychiatrist suitcase
full of Rorschach tests Zack Snyder's
300 of course starred Gerard Butler as
the lead role an actor who returns in
Snyder's ultimate cut of Watchmen as the
captain in the tales of the Black Friday
animated adaptation of the in-universe
comic of the same name Butler was
originally going to play that role in
live action but the expansive nature of
the shoot led to those 20 million dollar
sequences being cut but more on tales of
the Black Friday later because although
this pirate story might seem completely
random and out of place for both The
Watchman comic and movie the meaning
behind this comic goes hand in hand with
the overall story anyways as the
comedian in Ozymandias fight you can see
that these two dudes have a degree of
super strength about them as the
comedian is able to punch through walls
while Ozymandias is able to throw the
comedian around like it's nothing though
the Watchman ultimate cut movie is a
super close recreation of the original
comic giving some of the Watchmen a
degree of super strength is one of the
major changes Snyder made to his
adaptation both the median and
Ozymandias are normal non-powered heroes
in the comics so a lot of fans were
pretty upset when they first noticed
these superpowers as it very much
lessens the impact of the arrival of the
superpower Dr Manhattan to the world as
Dr Manhattan was Earth's first and only
superpowered hero in that comic in the
original book John osserman's
transformation into the nigh omnipotent
Dr Manhattan made non-super-powered
crime Fighters feel obsolete much like
Einstein's scientific discovery that
Timeless relative made John osterman's
watchmaker of a father feel obsolete in
his profession so obsolete in fact that
he threw his watchmaking equipment off
of a balcony and quit being a watchmaker
altogether as soon as he found out right
before encouraging his son John to
follow in Einstein's footsteps rather
than his own and this is why I believe
Alan Moore calling this comic about
obsolete Heroes The Watchmen was so
perfectly reflective of Dr Manhattan's
watchmaker father so having super
powered Watchmen in this movie
adaptation sort of takes away from that
specific impact of Dr Manhattan's
arrival I'm a crime-finding community
but that's just me but anyways as the
two fights the comedian crashes into a
pinup of his former Minutemen colleague
Sally Jupiter which very much points to
his obsession with her later on when we
get a flashback of the comedian burning
Ozymandias his map of the nation we can
see that the comedian uses a Sally
Jupiter lighter to do so so this dude
has been Sally's biggest and creepiest
fan for a long while now a fan finally
getting the sweet Karma he deserves at
the hand of Ozymandias for forcing
himself on Sally all those years ago
rest in pavement you son of a [__]
Ozymandias is about to throw the
comedian out the window the comedian Ian
laughs and says it's a joke it's all a
joke mother forgive me then blood from
the comedian smile drips onto his smiley
face pin to form the legendary piece of
Watchman iconography having blood Drift
from the comedian's smile to form a
bloody tear on his smiley face pin is a
perfect symbolic summary of the
comedian's whole lifestyle of laughing
through the pain of existing in a
chaotic world ruled by self-righteous
hypocritical men an internal pain that
he shows most prominently when he
drunkenly stumbles into his best friend
of me maulik's apartment later on in the
story where the Comedian says mother
forgive me again after cryptically
crying while confessing his crimes to a
career criminal with cancer anyways
after the comedian Takes a Tumble down
onto the streets to Unforgettable by Nat
King Cole the movie switches the
soundtrack up and plays The Times They
are a changing by Bob Dylan during a
montage of how the times of chains since
the start of vigilantism first we can
see imagery of Hollis Mason the original
Night Owl punching a gunman in front of
the Gotham opera house as A well-dressed
man a woman in a pearl necklace and
their Butler look on this is of course a
reference to Thomas and Martha Wayne's
assassination from the Batman comics an
assassination that the original Night
Owl stops to prevent the tragic origin
of Batman in this universe we can even
see that Zack Snyder snuck in some
posters of 1940s Batman number one
behind Night Owl to really drive that
Batman reference home then when the
title card of the movie comes up we get
an extremely faithful Recreation of the
Minutemen group photo that was
originally included in Alan Moore's
Watchman comic the Minutemen were of
course America's first ever coming
together of mass Vigilantes according to
Hollis Mason in his book under the hood
that detailed his own career as well as
the rise and fall of American Vigilantes
Mason was inspired to become the crime
fighter Night Owl ever since America's
first vigilante hooded Justice started
making a difference on the streets and
massive waves in the media with the two
later joining forces with the Minutemen
from left to right in the photograph we
have Ursula's on Silhouette who
unfortunately ends up being murdered for
being in a lesbian relationship Brian
Lewis the Mothman who ends up getting
sent off to sunnycrest Asylum after
developing a major mental illness on top
of a serious drinking problem after the
pressures of crime fighting get to him
Bill Brady's dollar bill the superhero
mascot for department store whose corpse
we see after he gets shot at Point Blank
Range after his cape got caught in a
revolving door Edna Mode was onto
something no capes no kips
how was Mason's Night Owl who we see get
beaten to death by the not tops gang
later on in the film Captain Metropolis
who ends up being the one to assemble
the Minutemen ends up being decapitated
by a car accident in the comics then we
have the first silk Specter Sally
Jupiter who is Lori's mom hooded Justice
the world's first vigilante whose true
identity is never revealed before he
disappears without a trace following the
outlawing of crime fighting with Eddie
Blake's the comedian in his old yellow
boiler suit kneeling in front of them
all then a little later during this
Montage after we see yet another one of
Sally Jupiter's pinup art on the Enola
Gay bomber plane that just bombed
Hiroshima Japan we can see famous
photographer Alfred ernstadt taking this
universe's version of the iconic VJ Day
in Times Square photo marking America's
victory over Japan with the hero
silhouette filling in for the male
soldier in the original photograph and
unfortunately because this lesbian kiss
was done during the massively intolerant
time of 1945 you can see a group of
stupid judgmental [__] reminiscing in
the background as they kiss it is this
type of hateful homophobic mentality
that would end up getting silhouette and
her partner killed in bed while reading
a news article about their sexcapades
then a little later during Sally
Jupiter's retirement party we can see
Zack Snyder have the Minutemen recreate
Leonardo da Vinci's the Last Supper
which is fitting considering that this
would be the last supper of the
Minutemen as a bunch of these team
members are about to be taken out of the
picture and after that we can see
President John F Kennedy shaking the
blue hand of Dr Manhattan before getting
brutally assassinated by the comedian an
event that Dr Manhattan actually foresaw
well before he met JFK in the comics in
the scenario the comedian is of course
the badge man from The Conspiracy that
hypothesizes that there was a second
shooter with a bright badge on his chest
that shot JFK from a grassy knoll but in
the Watchman universe that bright badge
was actually the comedian's smiley face
pin and as Sally Jupiter has a fight
with her husband in front of a young
Lori about her sleeping with the
comedian we can see a news report
showing the deadly protest of Vietnamese
Buddhist monk take Quang duck who died
on June 11 1963 after lighting himself
on fire on the streets of Saigon in
protests of the inhumane religious
intolerance of the South Vietnamese
government shout out to our editor
Matthew for catching this one but on top
of this television set we can see that
Zack Snyder made sure to include the
snow globe that Lori ends up staring
into to drown out her parents shouting
in the comics then after this we can see
rorschach's calling card that he leaves
next to two badly beaten up criminals
that roshek tied to a fire hydrant with
the symbol on the piece of paper of
course being rorschach's drawing of a
Rorschach test which was a form of
psychological test invented by Swiss
cycle analyst Herman Rorschach in 1921
that involved using symmetrical ink
blots on patients and recording their
associative responses which is what the
crime fighter Rorschach bases his mask
on I particularly love how the villain's
Rorschach beats up are lying there in
the same Double L shape that that
Warshak leaves behind on his Rorschach
test calling card with the dots being
their heads and the elves being their
bodies lying back to back against the
fire hydrant nice little subtle
symbolism there by Zack Snyder then
after we see Cuban leaders Fidel Castro
and the Soviet Union's Leonard bresnev
look over their stockpile of nuclear
missiles that fueled the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962. we could see images of
what appears to be the march on the
Pentagon protest of October 1st 1967. as
we can see imagery of a woman putting a
flower inside of a rifle which is a
reference to Bernie Boston's iconic
flower power photograph taken at that
protest March a March that had no
fatalities in real life but ended up
being a lot more deadly in the Watchmen
Universe then after this we can see
iconic artist Maestro Andy Warhol in an
art gallery showing off his new Night
Owl pop art to the world but if you look
behind him you can also see a Rorschach
ink block exhibit as well suggesting
that Warhol is a massive fan of crime
fighting heroes in this universe but
this is before we see footage of Neil
Armstrong's moon landing and hear
Armstrong saying good luck Mr Gorski as
he stares at Dr Manhattan on the surface
of the Moon which is a reference to an
urban legend that states that Neil
Armstrong after he said his iconic one
small step for man one giant leap for
mankind also uttered the cryptic
sentence good luck Mr Gorski and while
people were trying to figure out who
this Mysterious Mr Gorski was someone
came up with a ridiculous story of Mr
Gorski being one of Neil Armstrong's
childhood neighbors who he overheard
asking for a blowy from Mrs Gorski to
which Mrs Gorski apparently replied oral
sex I'll give you oral sex when the Kid
Next Door walks on the moon which is
what Neil Armstrong does however both
the gorskis and Neil Armstrong's good
luck Mr Gorski are both urban legends
that never actually happened in real
life but it's still super fun to see
Zack Snyder include that reference here
then after we see Ozymandias stand for
photos in front of Studio 54 we can see
him walk up to David Bowie Mick Jagger
and the villa people then right after
this we can see the Watchman team taking
a group photo in front of the photos of
their Minutemen predecessors in the
comics this team isn't called The
Watchman like it is in the movie but
instead The Crime Busters the term
Watchman is never actually used to refer
to the Crime Busters in the comics but
is instead a reference to the famous
Roman poet juvenile when he wrote kiss
custodiet espos custodias I don't know
Latin so I probably ruined that terribly
but it roughly translates into who will
guard the guards themselves and then
later who watches the Watchman which is
a phrase that we can see graffitied on
the television storefront at the start
of the film and just graffitied in
different places throughout the movie
Zack Snyder would later go on to leave
this Latin phrase on a nearby wall
during Batman and Superman's fight and
Batman v Superman as a direct reference
to his Watchmen movie but anyways as the
Watchman pose for the photograph Laurie
the new silk Specter is positioned in
between her father the comedian and a
photograph of her mother Sally Jupiter
Dr Manhattan and ozymandi is are framed
within the American flag behind them
foreshadowing their future collaboration
and Dan dreyberg's night owl is
positioned right in front of Hollis
Mason's original Night Owl then we can
see through the windows of a television
store the presidential term limits have
been repealed allowing President Nixon
to clinch himself more terms in office
while also outlying on sanctioned
Vigilantes we can also see a broadcast
of the Doomsday Clock being set to Five
Minutes to Midnight before nearby
protesters are engulfed by the Flames of
a Molotov cocktail thrown at the
television store window very much meant
to symbolize the nuclear flames of
Armageddon that threatened the entire
world during this cold war setting then
as the camera zooms out from the street
cleaner watching the comedian's blood
from the pavement up to the detectives
in the comedian's apartment we can
actually see Warshak as his alter ego
Walter Kovacs without his mask holding a
sign that says the end is nigh likely
analyzing the point of impact right
before he makes his way into the
apartment these two detectives in the
comedians Department are actually the
first characters that speak in the
original Watchman comic and much of
their dialogue is actually ripped
straight from those opening pages and
during a quick zoom out from these
detectives we can actually see a blimp
floating over the city that says ganga
Diner ganga Diner is actually the diner
that Dan and Lori end up having a date
in later on in the film then right
before Rorschach picks up the comedian's
pin and starts his extremely comic book
accurate monologue a newspaper flies
onto the street that has a pale horse
headline on one page and a Doomsday
Clock at five to midnight headline on
the other Pale Horse is the name of a
famous death metal band in this universe
that actually performs on the night that
Ozymandias attacks the world in the
comic this is super fitting considering
that Pale Horse is also a direct
reference to death one of the Horsemen
of the Apocalypse from The Book of
Revelations chapter 6 verse 8. as
Rorschach goes through the comedian's
apartment we can see him pick up a
newspaper article of the comedian's
takedown of the notorious villain the
Italian Shadow a famous Italian assassin
brutally taken out by The Comedians less
than restrained fighting style then
Rorschach finds another newspaper
article that details how the comedian
took down and arrested Malik back in
February 1970 but anyways after
Rorschach ditches the scene of the crime
we meet both versions of night owl in
the form of the old Hollis Mason played
by Stephen mccatty and the current Night
Owl played by Patrick Wilson in his
first DC Comics role before playing the
villainous Ocean Master in the first
Aquaman movie on Mason's desk we can see
a photograph of his days as a police
officer along with some toy cars and
books on cars representing his love of
repairing automobiles in his Youth and
in his retirement we can also see copies
of his book under the hood which details
how Mason became one of the first
superheroes in the world as Night Owl as
well as the rise and fall of America's
first superhero team the Minutemen the
ultimate cut of Watchmen also includes a
under the hood documentary detailing
these behind the scenes details of the
Golden Age Minuteman it's a super great
documentary and I highly recommend it
you can also see the walls Hollis
Mason's house covered with owl Decor
before we get a shot of Mason's TV
showing a news broadcast detailing the
Keen act which was the law signed by
Nixon to make vigilante heroism illegal
you know much like we saw on movies like
The Incredibles or Captain America Civil
War during that shot of the TV we can
see a book on the side called equation
for Evil by Philip Caputo which was a
detective story surrounding a horrific
hate crime that was actually published
in 1996 in our reality so since Washman
takes place in the 80s Hollis Mason
couldn't possibly have owned that book
however the Watchman movie is not afraid
to throw a timeline breaking book or two
in the background as later on in the
film right before Lori accidentally sets
night owl's basement on fire you can
actually see a copy of the Watchman
number 7 comic on Dan dryberg's desk
which is the very comic where Laurie
accidentally sets night owl's basement
on fire I find it super hilarious how
the Watchman comic technically already
exists in this movie Universe because
Dan should have seen all of his chaos in
his life coming and this comic is right
next to a picture of the Twilight lady
who was a villain Night Owl put away a
long time ago that had a deep attraction
to Night Owl so much so that she sent
him a picture of herself their Dynamic
very much mirroring Batman and Catwoman
but anyways after Dan finds that
Rorschach has broken into his apartment
for all of his sweet sweet beans they
head to night owl's basement Lair where
we can see both night owls regular and
Arctic Night Owl suits on display in a
glass case towards the end of their
conversation Rorschach angrily refers to
president Richard Nixon as tricky dick
which was the derogatory name Nixon's
political opponent started to call him
during his run for Senate in California
in 1950 and seeing that Nixon is on his
fifth term as president in this story
some would argue that that dick was
tricky indeed we then get a shot of
night owl's Crescent Moon shaped
throwing knives which of course are
extremely reminiscent to those of
Marvel's Moon Knight which then leads us
to our first piece of the animated tales
of the Black Friday pirate comic series
being read by Bernie at his buddy
Bernard's newsstand this tragic pirate
Adventure comic being told alongside the
original Watchman story was writer Alan
Moore's way of showing how the comic
book medium often time reflects what's
going on in real life because much like
Watchman antagonist ozymandias's main
mission of saving the world from nuclear
Armageddon had the dark foundations of
countless dead bodies many of whom were
his former colleagues the captain in
Tales of the Black Fighter mirrors that
by building a boat of dead bodies in
order to head back home and save his
family from the pirates of the Black
Friday who killed all of his crew
however after drinking so much seawater
while sailing on this boat of dead men
for so long the captain loses his touch
on reality completely as his fear of
what the Black Friday could do to his
family warps him from being a rational
thinking good man into a fearful Beast
of a Savage and that mindset is how the
captain ends up savagely beat leaving
his wife to death after his warped mind
mistook her for a Black Friday pirate
World War 3 was ozymandias's Black
Friday and his fear of World War III
warped his mind so completely that he
was willing to give a bunch of people
cancer as well as kill the comedian
Malik millions of human beings and
finally worshak just to prevent his fear
from possibly becoming a reality
Rorschach is even represented in the
Black Friday story as the captain's
bloody sails as the bloodstains on the
sale constantly changed their appearance
to look like bloody symmetrical
Rorschach tests much like the remains of
rorschach's body looks like after Dr
Manhattan popped all the Human Bean
juice out of his body just so Ozymandias
can keep his dark secret but anyways
after that animation ends we see Bernie
reading the tales of the Black Friday
comic with a poster of the comic behind
him that shows us that the comic is
published by DC Comics in this reality
much like the original Watchman Comics
were we can also see a poster for the
Pale Horse band behind Rorschach as he
waits for his newspaper then the movie
fittingly transitions from the Black
Friday sequence directly to ozymandias's
office where Dan dreyberg picks up a
Time Magazine cover with Ozymandias
shaking the hand of Dr Manhattan with
the cover of the New Yorker right behind
that having an artist Recreation of that
very same handshake we can see that
Adrian has also had appearances in both
Forbes and The Economist as well but one
particular thing of note about this
scene is that in the comics it's not
Night Owl that visits Ozymandias to warn
him of a hero killer but Rorschach
himself and rather than admiring
ozymandias's action figures of The
Watchmen like Night Owl does Rorschach
condemns Ozymandias for making toy
soldiers of himself and though Rorschach
doesn't appear in this scene you can
actually see Rorschach with his human
face and the end is nice sign spying on
Dan and Lori during their first date and
then later on at the comedian's funeral
studying the attendees and later while
Ozymandias watches Eddie Blake get
buried we get a flashback to his most
prominent memory of the comedian when
Eddie Blake burned his crime map as the
comedian laughing at the futility of the
watchman's effort to save the world in
the face of Armageddon is likely what
first sparked ozymandias's deep fear of
World War III however if we actually
look at this crime map we can see that
the Watchmen weren't exactly the best
crime fighters in the world as sexual
promiscuity black unrest and anti-war
demonstrations were some things high on
their priority list for policing and
speaking of anti-war demonstrations
night owl's most prominent memory of the
comedian plays out in the form of the
two Heroes arriving to an anti-vietnam
War demonstration that they were tasked
to break up the two arrive in night owls
owl themed combat plane that he
nicknamed Archie after the fictional
Merlin's pet owl Archimedes and choosing
I'm your Boogeyman by Casey and the
Sunshine Band for this scene was a
fantastic choice by Snyder as the
comedian was very much a boogeyman type
figure to a lot of people on the other
side of his guns and while the comedian
is firing on the protesters he tells
Night Owl that he hasn't had this much
fun since Woodward and Bernstein which
heavily implies that the comedian was
involved with the assassinations of
political reporters Bob Woodward and
Carl Bernstein in this universe two
people who were instrumental in exposing
Richard Nixon in the Watergate scandal
so Richard Nixon's re-election is likely
due to the comedian keeping the
Watergate scandal out of the papers and
in the comics the comedian jokingly says
that he had nothing to do with Woodward
and Bernstein's death but for nobody to
ask him where he was during Kennedy's
assassination which is kind of hilarious
considering what he does to JFK in the
movie's opening that dude killed all
three of those [__] then when
the comedian shoots someone for spraying
who watches the Watchmen on a nearby
wall with an American flag you can see
that the words on the wall seem to read
America welcomes Vietnam as our 51st
state pointing to America's colonization
of Vietnam after winning the war but
anyways when worshak goes to interrogate
Malik at his apartment you can see some
playing cards in a drawer that Rorschach
opens this is a reference to Malik being
a magician-themed villain back in the
day and more playing cards can be seen
on the walls outside of Malik's
apartment later on in the film when
Rorschach is being wrongfully arrested
for his murder then after Lori has her
surprise threesome with Dr Manhattan
only to find out that he was cheating on
her with science that [__] nerd we
can see Dr Manhattan working with Adrian
white on his subatomic Quantum unified
intrinsic field device that Adrian would
ultimately end up repurposing to frame
Dr Manhattan for the deaths of millions
of people at the end of the film this is
one of the biggest changes Zack Snyder
made from the original Source material
as comic book Ozymandias actually
genetically Engineers a giant psychic
squid to attack the world in order to
force an end to the Cold War instead of
using these Dr Manhattan bombs however
Zack Steiner made sure to make the
acronym for ozymandias's subatomic
Quantum unified intrinsic field device
to be squid as a nod to book's original
ending then later we can see Dr
Manhattan being interviewed by Ted
Koppel a real-life broadcast journalist
being portrayed by actor Ron fassler in
the movie however that interview quickly
heads South fast forcing Dr Manhattan to
[__] off to Mars something that
President Richard Nixon and his
right-hand man Henry Kissinger are
forced to address as the Doomsday Clock
moves towards Two Minutes to Midnight
and a little after this that same giant
blimp from before advertising gunga
Diner floats right outside Adrian's
office prior to his staged attack
followed directly by that ganga dinner
date between Lori and Dan that I
mentioned before then as Dan and Lori
leave the diner one of ozymandius's
pyramid transnational trucks can be seen
driving down the street then later when
we get the flashback of Rorschach
butchering that child killer to death I
couldn't help but notice that this
moment goes significantly different in
the book with Rorschach instead opting
to handcuff the killer to a furnace and
burning his house down while offering
the killer a saw to cut his arm off if
he wanted to escape the Flames which he
doesn't and speaking of Rorschach and
arms getting cut off that moment where
big figure Cuts one of his goons arms
off to get to Rorschach in his cell
didn't actually happen in the source
material as big figure ends up telling
one of his other goons to cut Lawrence's
throat instead and rather than using a
saw to cut the bars like the goons do in
the movie Big figure actually uses a
blowtorch in the comic which is why a
big figure says that he wants to smell
Rorschach cooking that line doesn't
really work as well in the movie because
there's no blowtorch and a little later
when the not tops gang plan to kill
Hollis Mason at Bernard's newsstand we
can see a billboard for meltdowns a
popular candy produced by Vite
Industries themed after the nuclear
tensions of the Cold War anything to
make money right and while we're on the
subject of Adrian vit when night owl and
Rorschach break into ozymandias's office
to search through his business files
Night Owl comes across a folder on a
floppy disk that just says Boys on it if
Rorschach was the one on the computer
instead of Night Owl his suspicions of
Ozymandias being gay would likely be
confirmed to him and towards the end of
the film when night owl and Rorschach
are approaching the nefarious fake
Pharaoh's Fortress Ozymandias can be
seen watching them on his wall of TV
screens and some of the other things
that Ozymandias is watching on that wall
include The Day the Earth Stood Still A
Marvin the Martian cartoon Rambo
Fail-Safe the road warrior and the
original 300 Spartans movie from 1962
another allusion to Snyder's 300 movie
and finally seconds before ozymandias's
bomb detonates on New York we can see
Rorschach psychiatrist watch freeze at
10 seconds to midnight both symbolizing
how close all the people in New York
were to their Annihilation as well as
how close the world was towards total
nuclear destruction but that is it for
this breakdown of the ultimate cut of
Watchmen thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
Master retainment on Twitter and
Instagram and anywhere I am on the
social media is if you guys want to see
me post some weird [__] but most
importantly do not forget to subscribe
to heavy spoilers here on YouTube We got
some really fun stuff planned for you
guys in the future so do not miss any of
it click that Bell or I will yell
disconnect will yell but I'll be very
disappointed if you don't
yeah
just kidding do what you want I love you
guys so much and I'll see you guys later
bye